ooh off the heel not good you would get
made fun of so bad in parkour if you
were doing that my name is lorena abreu
and i am a professional parkour athlete
and stunt woman i started parkour in
2013 then got to do some parkour for
cirque du soleil today we're going to be
looking at parkour stunts for film and
tv and judge how real they are
i
love this scene because it's shot kind
of like a parkour video you know mostly
wide i like just being able to see the
parkour clearly
so technique wise the underbar excellent
you go
feet first you catch with your arms and
you pull the bar through you like this i
don't really see them doing anything for
no reason which tends to happen a lot
in other films that have parkour chase
scenes
it looks like the two
ninja space guys
are only doing kong vaults in this scene
a kong is a vault where you use both
hands to push down on the wall that
you're vaulting over and your feet come
through the center in real life these
guys were actually running for their
absolute lives i think
some of those kong vaults would have
been safeties instead a safety vault is
when you put
one hand down on the obstacle and one
foot down on the obstacle the other foot
comes through the middle so the reason
that one is the most efficient is
because
you can actually push off that foot
that's planted on the wall and get speed
venic is actually doing
mostly
safety vaults and speed vaults the speed
vault is a safety vault but without
putting your foot down
[Music]
vertical pull swings are one of my
favorite things ever their technique for
the vertical pull swing was great they
led with their arms and swung their legs
behind them and around
to redirect their momentum
i would not recommend
swan diving off of a building chest
first unless
you were competing in a belly flop
competition and landing in a pool on
some water so what i would do instead is
do a turn vault and climb down
for me it's a 10 out of 10. it is 100
legit parkour unless you include the
swan dive
this scene from the office is the bane
of so many parkour athletes existence
but i
love it this is parkour
internet sensation of 2004 and it was in
one of the bond films it's pretty
impressive the goal is to get from point
a to point b as creatively as possible
the clips he showed on the laptop were
legit their guy was doing tic tacs and
180 wall runs and
you know one of those old school 2004
wall flips i think this was great
exposure for parkour because jim's
definition was legit and put the word
parkour in a lot of people's vocabulary
and yeah the downsides is that a lot of
people didn't take it seriously nobody
likes getting yelled hardcore parkour in
the streets while we're training it
happens all the time we go one at a time
here it is here it is uh truck to
refrigerators to dumpster 360 spin onto
the palace that's actually probably the
most realistic portrayal of planning a
parkour line that i've seen in film or
television we call sequences of
movements that we usually film and post
on youtube or on instagram i'll run
we're standing around
we see something that we want to do oh i
can do this from here to there okay now
how do i connect it all backflip gainer
into the trash
a gainer is a backflip that travels
forwards the level of talent has
increased so dramatically in recent
years that i actually think there are
now multiple people that could probably
do
a running gainer off of that wooden
platform into the recycling bin
but yeah that's just not not really a
thing i want to rate it 10 out of 10 for
how much i enjoyed it
in terms of parkour realism i don't know
a two
doing a descent like that going straight
from arms to catching only with your
arms again you would rip your shoulders
out of their sockets unless you were
unbelievably strong they could have
made this scene 10 000 times more
realistic
by doing the actual descent technique of
having her
hit her feet first before landing on the
lower walls with her hands in a cat
position
the technique was super legit in her
takeoff the pressure she's doing up on
the window that's legit you can
definitely stay there in that position
her little
prep ops to the side before jumping this
way all of that was legit the only thing
that was not legit with that move was
the distance you know how hard it is
to jump that far without coming off of
the wall
so she has to jump that hard and somehow
like stay skating on the surface of the
wall
to go that far over there
uh no i rate this scene from alice in
borderland
uh
two
this is like almost parkour
bastion just did and his run up the beam
100 authentic a cat leap in parkour is
when you jump to the face of a wall so
you're either hanging on to the top of
the wall which is the most common or
you're grabbing onto the sides and
crimping it like sebastian just did
sebastian fukan is one of the founders
of parkour he can probably do it even
faster and just like anything else in
parkour you always want to go feet first
because feet forwards is the rule it's
the law and you can never break it
unless you're doing a dive kong or dive
roll you never want to go hands first
because that's
there are plenty of guys that can do
that no problem and much higher and on
things much skinnier i'd imagine that
craig or his stunt double had wires
running up that crane just for safety
the run-up for the jump was excellent so
the most important factor that goes into
doing a jump like this or any jump is
your run up your last three steps and
your foot placement that is the parkour
bible more experienced athlete will know
to map out their last three steps
way ahead of time i don't think craig
took stutter steps uh which maybe he
should have
it's really really easy to mix up your
steps when you're going into a running
jump in parkour you can see the
difference in parkour technique between
sebastian and craig sebastian's
character has a more tight compact
airform
in the middle of his jumps whereas
craig's body is more extended
and a little bit less in control so in
parkour that's why you're going to see
us tuck into a ball we're bringing our
knees to our chest and extending our
feet forwards to position your feet
correctly for the landing so
it makes sense that daniel craig's
character
would not know
that was a massive drop in real life the
reason why someone
like mr bond here would have missed his
feet the way he did would be because he
didn't get his feet properly in front of
him so when you do a drop precision
you generally don't tuck into a ball in
the air you always want to be aiming
your feet at what you're landing on so
he
undershot it his chest was too far
forward you always want to keep your
chest new
this character just did a classic
beautiful parkour roll you can take some
gnarly height drops if you can roll
correctly we generally go
hands first
at an angle so you don't get too much
impact in any one part of your body and
that's exactly what sebastian just
bond took this height drop i don't know
if this had to do with the weird little
which is a split leg thing that he did
at the take off for no reason but
he actually did a perfectly fine roll
when he landed it just appears in the
shot that he had too much momentum that
sent him flying off that's realistic
that can definitely happen based on
realism i would have to give it a nine
out of ten the techniques and the
physics of everything was all
fantastic
ooh off the heel not good you would get
made fun of so bad and parkour if you
were doing that any time you're doing
anything in parkour especially a stride
which is a jump off of one leg and
especially if it's off something skinny
you want to perform the movement off the
balls of your foot for safety and
power and efficiency
[Music]
his arm movements are legit whenever
you're jumping at something you want to
send your arms in the direction of what
you're jumping at if you're doing a
stride you'll often do
opposite arms to legs
you can definitely do that if you're
doing a massive jump
you don't really want to land in a
stride on just one leg it's a lot of
impact for no reason i would rate it
like an 8 out of 10 because he's doing
real parkour just with bad technique
[Music]
i love how he's just randomly doing
parkour in random places parkour
generally consists of jumping from
things to other things and not just
off of things so the spots where we'd
actually train to practice parkour is
walls that are more or less near other
walls but we can also practice on grass
to practice tricks to practice falling
which is extremely important falling
safely
[Music]
in terms of the skills that he's
practicing in this montage that is
100 percent
and expected of someone who is just
starting to do parkour so when you first
learn parkour you're going to learn the
jumps he did a little running jump
stride off of the end of that didn't
land with great technique but it's fine
because he's a beginner you're going to
learn the vaults that was a lazy ball
over the car it's all legit parkour
[Music]
the sketchiness of doing a full speed
running jump
from one level of a parking garage down
to another level of a parking garage
when you're a beginner it's just no
no
he had like no run up he took what like
five steps into that giant gap and not
even trying to sell the landing like
they literally just cut to him being on
another floor without the last scene
i would rate this uh nine out of ten for
realism big props to taylor lautner
[Music]
i don't know if they actually scaled
that entire building but
there's no reason to believe they
wouldn't because the yamakazee
absolutely did things like that so the
yamakazee are the quintessential
parkour team that invented what became
parkour as we know it today
i can't see much detailing in those
shoes i don't know if that was an
advertisement you can technically do
parkour in any shoes and you can do it
barefoot too you should do train
barefoot actually frequently to refine
your technique and strengthen all the
muscles in your feet so these shoes that
i'm wearing
the version with uh laces is actually
really good that is
an ideal midsole
that will protect you from most impact
[Music]
things like these flips if we're talking
parkour they're not efficient but
they're obviously fun and they're
stylish we tend to use the term free
running to describe anything that's
non-efficient that's generally used for
style whereas we use parkour to describe
efficient and power movements so i like
to look at it like a spectrum with
parkour on one end and free running on
the other i for example land somewhere
over here like i can do some flips but i
am mostly out jumping at stuff
so it looks like they were using their
legs a lot and scaling that building
when it comes to scaling things and when
it comes to doing parkour in general you
want to use your legs as much as
possible because they are the strongest
muscles in your body and the ones that
take the longest to exhaust when they
were going up on those concrete things
you could see that their arms were
mostly lacks and they were pushing with
their legs to come up on it
[Music]
taking height drops those early speed
vaults with the arm up here super
yamakaze style you can see the yamakaze
all kind of doing their own thing
everyone's doing something similar but
slightly different so in real life
what would determine which moves you
would choose depends on a number of
factors one what do you want to do
because we're generally doing parkour
for fun two your height could play a
role in it a jump might be huge for you
if you're my size but it might be small
for you if you're someone else i would
have to give it at least a 12 out of 10
because these are the yamakaze doing
what the yamakaze does
[Music]
a lot of people have asked the question
of whether or not what jackie chan did
in these movies could be considered
parkour because he was technically doing
it before anyone coined the term parkour
my answer to the question and what i
think is the objective correct answer
anyways is
yes i mean look at him like that's a
running plyo a plyo is when
you do
a jump with both feet to land with both
feet and immediately jump again with
both feet the idea is that you are
absorbing with both feet and using that
absorption as the prep for your next
takeoff he's throwing his arms the way
you should but again his chest is way
too far forward and he landed
face first into something
he is jumping onto all kinds of sketchy
stuff here things that are soft and
unreliable in real life we are not going
to be jumping to fabrics there's just so
much risk for
ankles for the thing itself collapsing
like it did there
for it launching you in a way that's
unexpected we generally like
reliable hard surfaces that are even
a lot of the moves that jackie chan does
in these old movies he's famous for his
wall runs and he'll do speed vaults and
laches which is swinging off a bar and
throwing yourself those are things that
jackie chan is known for that fit into
the modern toolbox of parkour moves that
we know of today for realism it's a 10
out of 10 because it's jackie chan
so this move that david bell does you
don't usually see that very often in
real life unless there was a gap
that was too big to jump so you would
need to run on the wall or off a ledge
on the wall to get to the other side or
to get around some bad guys like david
bell but
we generally use the term wall run to
describe going up a wall to
tack at
towards the bottom of the wall at an
angle with your foot to shoot you
upwards to scale a wall that is too tall
to otherwise get up a lot of people
credit him with being the father of
parkour but
based on my understanding of how things
went down
he
invented parkour along with the rest of
the yamakazee
i love the chase down the stairway scene
what makes this scene unique compared to
a lot of other parkour scenes from film
and tv is that david bell is doing a lot
of parkour in a closed and cramped space
he does a few moves for style points in
here that aren't very efficient like he
does a reverse at one point as he's
bounding down the stairs but grabbing
onto the railings and generally either
doing a speed vault or a turn vault
to bound and plyo down
is 100 realistic and exactly what you
would do if you were trying to get down
the stairs that fast doing parkour
vault to slam the door on the guy how do
you know he was there was he psychic i
don't know how he saw him from the other
side of that door the explosion
classic yamakazee
dramatic roof gap
david bell has definitely done roof gaps
that big he did a very dramatic kind of
flailing classic yamakaze getting away
from something explosive in real life
you would have a much more controlled
airform you would take off and
like i said
bring your knees in the direction of
your chest aim your feet at the landing
and roll upon impact just like david
bell perfectly did in here so if i were
to rate this based on realism i would
rate it a
7 or 8 out of 10
because i can't help but think about a
little bit more than just the parkour
because of his psychic ability to know
where the bad guys were going to be what
is my favorite parkour scene from film
or tv
um that is difficult i'm just gonna tell
you guys to watch the entirety of the
district b13 movie
a lot of height drops an iconic underbar
going down the staircase this was when
parkour was still more less at its
infancy
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video you should click the video above